you think the story is going to have a
happy ending happy endings are just
stories that haven't finished yet Brad
Pitt versus Angelina Jolie the animosity
is real nearly seven years after their
split and these two are still going at
it the battle today is over their 160
million dollar Winery seems like a lot
of dirty laundry playing out Brad calls
Angelina vindictive and just wants to
quote inflict harm on him in these new
court docks he says her actions are
severely and intentionally damaging Brad
is claiming that he would not have put
all of the time and energy and effort
that he put in into this company
if he
knew Angelina was going to go off and
try to sell it this is a war of words
times 100. what Angelina's Camp is
claiming is that Brad Pitt tried to
silence her ability to sort of speak
about these allegations of abuse by
including in the sale a
non-disparagement clause that uh
basically stopped her from being able to
talk about anything that might reflect
poorly on Brad Pitt I just want to
manage expectations Brad's filing comes
one day after he made his hilarious
return to scripted TV after more than
two decades remember friends appearing
in the finale of the FX comedy day
his performance including that
auto-tuned wrap will be submitted by the
show for a guest star comedy Emmy
until you love yourself
you can never love another
while things just seem to be getting
worse between Brad and Angie Kelly
Clarkson is coping with her difficult
divorce in a very Kelly kinda way she
just dropped the new Breakup Song
[Music]
yes I confess Kelly's divorce from
Brandon Blackstock was finalized last
year divorce is a really
her new song I hate love features Steve
Martin on Banjo and references two big
Hollywood romance movies
[Music]
Kelly's ex was mentioned on her show
today after her guest Priyanka Chopra
Jonas and Carrie Hart explained to her
what a push present is what is
when you have the baby you should get a
gift
back in 2017 Carrie gave pink this
motorcycle after the birth of their son
Jameson I built her this motorcycle as
you know as a thank you for being an
awesome mom and yeah birthing my child
yeah
so well you brought the bike I know that
should have been a red flag so you bro I
honestly don't know that he knew